want to start today with super
interesting video from the former
national security advisor john bolton
who went on cnn and casually admitted to
planning coups in the past now this is
fascinating not in that it's a huge
shock to any followers of american
foreign policy over the years that the
united states has been involved in uh
organizing and planning coups the
interesting part is this just sort of
casual and very nonchalant nature with
which john bolton says to jake tapper
listen i i've helped plan coups and what
donald trump did was not plan a coup and
the point that bolton was trying to make
was that trump may have had delusions
about staying in power even though he
didn't win
and he may have sort of casually said to
georgia officials or whoever find me
votes find me votes send fake slates of
electors or whatever
but that trump was not organized enough
trump was not smart enough trump was not
uh scheming enough
to really attempt a coup in any formal
sense and it's sort of a weird defense
of trump and in so doing he casually
says i've helped playing coups this when
you plan a coup it's much tougher than
what donald trump was uh was doing so
let's take a look at the first part of
the conversation a lifetime occurrence i
don't know that i agree with you to be
to be uh fair with all due respect uh
one doesn't have to be
brilliant to attempt a coup uh i
disagree with that as somebody who has
helped plan coup d'etat
not here but you know other places of
course uh it takes a lot of work and
that's not what he did it was coos are
really tough work guys just stumbling
around from one idea to another
ultimately he did unleash the rioters at
the capitol as to that there's no doubt
but not overthrow the constitution to
buy more time to throw the matter back
to the states to try and redo the issue
and if you don't believe that you're
going to overreact and i think that's a
real risk for the committee which has
done a lot of good work mostly when the
witnesses testify not when the members
are opining
it is invariably the case that when you
go too far trying to prove your case you
undermine it and i think you got to give
credit to the intelligence of the
american people to listen to the
witnesses okay so the point that bolton
is making is
what trump did was so unorganized that
it's really hard to call it a coup
attempt and bolton of course is
comparing what trump did
to the coup attempts he's been involved
in and they're much more meticulously
planned i guess bolton is saying bolton
is saying when i know how to plan coups
and it's way more organized and of
course that may be but that doesn't
change the intention of what donald
trump was trying to do now later in the
interview good for jake tapper i guess
he goes back to this issue but i do want
to mention one thing which
is that
bolton
while he sang the quiet parts out loud
obviously
tapper
was talking about attempting a coup
he said you don't have to be brilliant
to attempt a coup and bolton's saying to
successfully execute the coup
you actually do need to be
more brilliant more organized whatever
and it would have been important i think
for jake tapper to say well hold on a
second maybe you're right that for the
coup to succeed you need to be more
intelligent or organized or whatever but
i'm talking about the attempt and trump
attempted and failed maybe due to
incompetence sort of talking past each
other in that sense and tapper kind of
kind of lets him get away with it it a
little bit reminds me of this infinite
monkey theorem i don't know this is just
a silly thing well maybe it's not silly
but it's the idea that if you put a
bunch of monkeys in a room with a bunch
of typewriters or maybe word processors
or maybe personal computers or ipads or
whatever with word processing software
if you put them in there long enough and
let them tap away eventually one of them
will stumble across you know a
shakespearean play or something and they
they will write it and the idea being
okay as incompetent as donald trump
might have been
if you continue allowing incompetent
people to feel around in the dark for
ways to stay in power eventually they
might successfully do it you might get a
you know a thousand failed coup attempts
and then eventually you get a successful
one doesn't really make it any less
dangerous if those are the intentions of
someone in such a position of power jake
tapper goes back to it and so let's look
at that now and um john bolton doesn't
want to get into the specifics of the
coups that he has planned to
anathematize the rest of the republican
party and that's unacceptable i i do
want to ask a follow-up um
when we were talking about what is
capable of what you need to do to be
able to plan a coup
and you you cited your expertise having
planned coups i'm not going to get into
the specifics but uh it's so successful
well i wrote about venezuela in uh in
the book and uh it it turned out not to
be successful not that we had all that
much to do with it but i saw what it
took for an opposition to try and
overturn an illegally elected president
and they failed the notion that donald
trump was half as competent as the
venezuelan opposition is laughable again
this is sort of i mean what he's saying
is crazy obviously the the fact that
he's
planning clues is really hard work jake
trust me take it for me
um again
if you try to bribe someone and the
target rejects the va the bribe
you've still committed a crime assuming
it can be proven of course
uh just because you were incompetent at
doing you might plan a murder
and do it so incompetently that it
doesn't succeed it doesn't mean it isn't
attempted murder and this and this
insistence on trump's just not nearly as
competent as i was and even we weren't
able to successfully do the coup is a
crazy defense
but i think there's i feel like you're
this other stuff you're not telling me
though i think i'm sure there is i think
there's another point here that that
came out in the testimony that's not
been stressed enough uh testimony all
right okay so there's now he's going on
to other things so stunning stunning
stuff
casually admitting and saying i'm not
going to tell you about all the coups
i've planned but i'm much smarter than
trump and even i didn't succeed in many
of them incredible stuff and just the
reality of american foreign policy
there's no surprise it is
the the the real shocker is
it is this casual for the neocons like
bolton
that the us
plans and attempt and often fails at
executing coups it's just part of what
they do and it's like ah we were we're
better at trump than trump added and so
trump trump's attempt is really no big
deal incredible stuff
we have a blockbuster new report uh out
of rolling stone
donald trump's lawyers increasingly
believe that mark meadows his own former
chief of staff
is going down legally and it seems as
though they may be getting closer and
closer to abandoning meadows now there's
a parallel story here to this
which is that yesterday i played for you
video
from the january 6 committee
wherein liz cheney says we are now aware
of donald trump personally calling a
forthcoming witness someone who has not
yet testified
and trying to tamper with the witness uh
trying to influence or in some way
affect their potentially forthcoming
testimony we don't know who that person
is but there's rampant speculation that
it's mark meadows and parallel to that
there is now this incredible story from
the from rolling stone that trump's
lawyers think meadows is going down and
the question now is how to minimize
the uh sort of secondary damage the
shrapnel with which others may be hit if
indeed mark meadows testifies and goes
down rolling stone writing exclusive
trump's lawyers think mark meadows is
going down the january 6 committee is
probing the former chief of staff's
finances rolling stone has learned
adding to a long list of legal headaches
as she opened the january six committee
on tuesday liz cheney ticked through a
list of names of people trump's legal
team have attempted to pin the blame for
the capital attack naming the
president's lawyers maga friendly
lawmakers and others mark meadows didn't
make the list yet but trump's inner
circle increasingly views meadows as a
likely fall guy for the former
president's attempts to overturn the
2020 election members of trump's legal
team are actively planning certain
strategies around meadows downfall
including possible criminal charges
trump has himself begun the process of
distancing from some of his one-time
senior aides alleged actions around
january 6th this is the new part meadows
already bleak legal prospects could get
even worse because rolling stone has
learned that the january 6 committee has
been quietly probing his financial
dealings and any new revelations would
add to an already long list of unethical
and potentially illegal actions he's
accused of taking on behalf of donald
trump quote everyone is strategizing
around the likelihood that mark is in a
lot of trouble says a lawyer close to
the former president everyone who knows
what they're doing anyway rolling stone
spoke to eight sources familiar with the
matter
everyone's still in trump's orbit or on
his legal defense or in republican
circles in contact with trump
everybody's speaking
candidly because they were provided
anonymity so there's a few interesting
components to this
first of all it would not be unlike
donald trump to run a multi-pronged
strategy publicly distance from the
people that might be going down
and privately try to influence them in
order for them to damage you less and
it's completely speculative but there's
the question was the phone call that
trump made to try to tamper with a
witness
uh to mark meadows the other part of
this
is that meadows is actually the the
financial questions around meadows and
the voting questions have been going on
for a while if i recall correctly
there's sort of two avenues to this and
it's sort of strange that everybody
around trump has these problems mark
meadows had one issue
related to voter registration uh i'm
kind of giving you the 30 000 foot view
but apparently meadows owns a trailer
somewhere
that he has never even been to
and was registered to vote at that
address which is weird and also
registered to vote elsewhere so that was
one thing we talked about maybe six
eight nine months ago something like
that
and then again if i'm going for memory i
believe that on the financial side
there's something tax related to mark
meadows and it also may relate to what
state do you
formally live in or whatever the case
may be
so if and how that connects directly to
trump is a question but anything that
puts him more on the radar of
investigators is potentially bad for
donald trump so as far as the witnesses
there's a january 6 hearing sometime
next week i don't even know that it's
been scheduled specifically yet
and we don't know who the witness is
going to be who the witnesses
potentially are going to be we've been
told it's going to be absolutely
stunning could it be meadows uh could it
be steve bannon i don't know
but it could be maybe the most
interesting day of the hearings all
together liz cheney made clear this is a
witness you have not yet seen
and um that there's a long list of
people that could fall into that
category but we will soon know and if
meadows goes down i mean remember
the the strategy from these people trump
etc has been whenever anyone gets in
trouble minimize their role minimize
their role in the trump campaign or the
administration or in whatever
it's going to be
impossible to minimize the role
of the last and final chief of staff
that donald trump had
who was
personally doing the bidding of trump in
the lead-up to the january six riots i
mean they'll try of course they'll try
but it's not going to be i think
even the average american as we like to
say is going to see through that let me
know your thoughts who do you expect to
be the blockbuster witness coming up
next week you can find me on twitter at
deepakman and we'll be covering it of
course
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
i want to go back now to this viral
story of a 10 year old in ohio
impregnated after being raped
and subsequently going to indiana for an
abortion because of ohio's strict
abortion laws now we covered the story
as it was reported a week or two ago it
was either early last week or late the
previous week
and it's an incredibly disturbing story
not surprisingly many on the right said
it was just a made-up story and we're
going to get to that in the second part
of this segment but that's not where i
want to start where i want to start is
the follow-up to the story which is that
an arrest has now been made of the
alleged perpetrator and this is part of
what has now shifted the narrative from
the american right on the story which we
will get to in due time so here's the
latest the columbus dispatch reporting
arrest made in rape of ohio girl that
led to indiana abortion drawing
international attention now part of the
reason why it drew international
attention national and international was
that this happened in the immediate
aftermath of the supreme court uh
announcing that roe v wade is no more
that the fundamental right to an
abortion in most cases in the country is
no more and people like south dakota
governor christie gnome
the mississippi house speaker whose name
i forget and others were asked what
about cases where a kid is raped and
impregnated 12 year old was the example
that was often given
would you feel comfortable forcing them
to carry a child to term and one of the
reactions was these are imaginary
situations these are mere hypotheticals
we don't deal in hypothetical and very
quickly we had a real story and that was
much of why the story became viral in
the way that it did well the follow-up
is the is the following
a columbus man has been charged
with impregnating a ten-year-old ohio
girl whose travel to indiana to seek an
abortion led to international attention
following the supreme court overturning
roe v wade and the activation of ohio's
abortion law
gerson fuentes 27 years old was arrested
tuesday after police say he confessed to
raping the child on at least two
occasions he's since been charged with
rape a felony in the first degree in
ohio
columbus police were made aware of the
girl's pregnancy through a referral by
frankly franklin county children's
services made by her mother on june 22.
on june 30 the girl underwent a medical
abortion in indianapolis so first and
foremost
the indiana abortion part was a real
part of the story the right was
desperate to say that's fake
that's fake and let's find whatever
doctors are committing crimes here it
was a real part of the story
hewn the detective
also testified that dna from the clinic
in indianapolis is being tested against
samples from fuentes as well as the
child siblings to confirm contribution
to the aborted fetus as you can imagine
if that is confirmed this will be an
open and shut case now one other
interesting element here that i will
discuss
franklin county municipal court judge
cynthia ebner said the case did not
warrant fuentes who is believed to be an
undocumented immigrant to be held
without bond
ebner said a high bond was necessary due
to fuentes being a possible flight risk
and for the safety of the child
um
the bond was set at two million dollars
and it is unclear whether the individual
would be able to make that bond so a few
different things here number one
undocumented whoop that's a perk up word
for fox news fox news suddenly cares
about the story again when it was the
rape of a ten-year-old with a pregnancy
but unable to get an abortion
the story might be fake and it was not
an interesting story
all of a sudden now that the perpetrator
the believed perpetrator who has
allegedly confessed and whose guilt may
be proven by dna very soon is
undocumented now they care about the
story but they're spinning it and we'll
talk about that in the next segment now
of course if there's a dna match this is
going to be an open and shut case
and we will soon know that many of you
emailing me saying
if there isn't a case that requires uh
no bond
wouldn't it be this one because isn't
the individual if indeed he is an
undocumented immigrant potentially a
flight risk to get out of the country i
think that that's absolutely true and
it's weird to me that that bond was
granted that being said we don't know
the financial situation of this
individual two million dollar bond may
be an impossibility
uh and even if you have to come up with
10 with a bail bondsman 200 000 may be
an impossibility we just don't know it
may effectively be no bond don't know
the answer to that one other aspect to
this
very often in child rape cases i get
emails from people in the audience
saying
i can't wait for this guy to end up in
prison
where you know they'll often say
something like where bubba
is going to give this guy an even
stricter punishment than the time in
prison talking of course about prison
rape i've said this before and i will
say it again no matter how vile the
crime
and no matter how strict the sentence
which this is a very serious alleged
crime and the sentence should be very
severe
the the counting on
the lack of security in our prisons
so that people also are raped as part of
an additional punishment i think is
absolutely disgusting when and and i'm
not denying that it happens
but when people say you know child
molesters have it tough in prison
they're gonna end up raped themselves
and i like that
we have a problem in american prisons
that they are unable to keep inmates
safe
it should if you believe there should be
stricter punishments for certain crimes
well we can lobby for them we can we can
vote we can find elected officials or
whatever that will change the law to
make the punishment stricter but
relishing
off the record punishments that are the
result of
faulty prisons that aren't able to
protect inmates like for example prison
rape of child molester it's very hard
for me to say that that that's a good
thing or pre the punishment should be
that doled out by the justice system and
if this person is indeed the perpetrator
it should be a very severe punishment
but the the relishing the prison rape
stuff hard for me to get behind that
okay so that's the update on the story
let's now go to the right wing reaction
okay so check this out
when we first heard
about this
absolutely horrible story of a
ten-year-old girl
raped and impregnated in ohio unable to
get an abortion in ohio because of the
law having to go to indiana the right
wingers
started doing two things one is they
said it's fake it's a fake story it's
made up none of it is true none of this
is happening no one's going to indiana
absolutely not
and the second part of it was saying
is it a crime to go to indiana for an
abortion we've got to find the doctor
sending the girl to indiana we've got to
find the doctor performing the abortion
in indiana we need to charge these
people which is a crazy reaction but
let's focus on the first part which was
it's made up none of it is true well it
turns out that it is true
and suddenly because the suspected
rapist is believed to be an undocumented
immigrant they've quietly these
right-wingers who first said it was a
fake story they've started saying well
yeah
she had to go to indiana for an abortion
thanks to that no good illegal that joe
biden led let into the country now first
of all
i've seen no evidence that this
individual entered the country during
the biden administration be true may not
be completely irrelevant to the story
but check out some of these examples
governor christie gnome
uh tweeted
a week ago dana bash tried to trap me
with a story about a ten-year-old girl
who got an abortion i pointed out nobody
was asking about the pervert who raped
that child now it looks like the story
was fake to begin with
literal fake news
from the liberal media well it turns out
that that story is absolutely and
completely true and christinome uh just
called it fake for no reason there was
no reason to believe it was fake there's
a guy named clay travis okay he has a
radio show and he's on
um
some fox show he writes books and you
know this type of thing okay he tweeted
multiple times that the story is
straight straight up fake check these
out everything joe biden said here
appears to be a lie ohio law ohio a law
allows abortion for raped children and
more importantly there is zero evidence
that this actually happened tweeting
again media reports of a ten-year-old
girl being raped in ohio and having to
leave the state for an abortion appeared
to be completely made up
tweeting again clay travis rips apart
indie star and the rest of the leftist
media
for allowing the story about a
ten-year-old seeking an abortion to go
viral well the story was completely true
and now with absolutely no uh egg on his
face no embarrassment whatsoever which
he should be feeling clay travis updates
the story and says updating this viral
story which you said shouldn't have gone
viral a 27 year old illegal immigrant in
ohio has been arrested for raping a 10
year old girl the girl could have gotten
an abortion in ohio under state law but
traveled to indiana to have the abortion
instead so now the focus is well that's
an undocumented immigrant
ohio congressman jim jordan who by the
way does not exactly have a track record
of reporting and taking seriously
believed in alleged
uh assault of minors but that's a story
for a different day he deleted uh his
tweet he posted another lie anyone
surprised about the story
and then that tweet has mysteriously
disappeared sorry
that tweet has been deleted
they don't apologize they instill fear
and say it's the left-wing media that's
lying to you they can't be trusted they
can't be believed the entire thing is
made up then it turns out they were
lying and then they just move on to the
next thing now here
they have a little bit of an escape
shoot because the perpetrator the
alleged perpetrator is believed to be an
undocumented immigrant if it weren't for
that they would just be they wouldn't
even talk about the story they now have
a new angle a new straw to grasp onto
which is this is an undocumented
immigrant and it's joe biden's fault and
look at the terrible thing that an
undocumented immigrant did well you were
just saying that it never happened and
now the problem is a different one
completely predictable and again
they will very casually say the story is
fake
even when there is no reason to believe
that the story is fake it was very real
it's a tragedy it's a result in part of
the abortion laws that these very same
people want to be the laws in these
states that's where we are
and they just don't it's the trumpian
approach you can apologize you just move
on you pretend you were never wrong or
you move on to something else some shiny
new object they do it every time and
they're not going to stop we'll have
more on these stories on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
later on we're going to look at some
incredible video
of a republican congressman
talking about post-birth abortion
which isn't a thing i mean it quite
literally doesn't exist we'll get to
that later on in the show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com david pakman show
today we're going to be speaking with
lily geismer who's an associate
professor of history at claremont
mckenna college and also author of the
book left behind the democrats failed
attempt to solve inequality really great
having you on today i appreciate your
time
oh thank you so much for the invitation
so i mean i think an interesting place
to start or a logical place to start
would be
most of my audience i'm sure would agree
that at least the rhetoric and the
promises of the democratic party
relative to the republican party would
seem more likely to reduce inequality
and to sort of level the economic
disparities that we see in the united
states and yet to a great degree it
really hasn't happened and we could talk
about why that's the case we could say
well it's it's
despite every good intention it's simply
republican obstructionism and sort of
shift the blame elsewhere and and and
take that approach but you take a
different approach in the book can you
can you talk a little bit about the way
you see what you call the this failed
attempt to deal with inequality
absolutely and i think that one of the
issues which you've um
identified and is not and this is not to
say that the republican i think the
republican party is blameless in efforts
to address inequality but i think so
often there's an effort to just sort of
say
this it's all it putting putting blame
solely on the republican party for its
policies and one of the things i really
wanted to understand is that um why
inequity has increased so dramatically
in the united states um since the real
since the 1970s but especially since
1990s and to understand the democratic
party's
efforts to address it and why those
efforts didn't work and what i
came to
largely is the fact that um the
democratic party increasingly starting
in the 1970s started to
use try to use the private sector and
the market as a tool to address
inequality and what i want to understand
want to understand and what the book
addresses is is why those kinds of
programs um don't work or why that
approach um actually led to shrinking
the social welfare state and compounding
inequality and and really contributing
to many of the kind of problems we are
seeing today yeah so can you give us
like one
example that might be an easy easily
relatable one in terms of the idea of
how to use the private sector what was
done and why it did not work
well there's a lot and the book sort of
tracks a bunch of them yeah um one of
the really clear ones is um the efforts
to use programs like micro enterprise or
microfinance which was this very popular
tool in um especially the 1990s and
really beginning in the 1980s um people
like bill clinton had the idea so for
those of you who aren't familiar with
what microenterprise is it's the idea of
kind of giving small loans um to poor
people to start their own businesses um
and so you start sort of micro
entrepreneurs
it was first experimented with in the
global south especially in bangladesh by
someone named muhammad yunus
and the clintons in arkansas the 80s
become really enamored in this with this
program and that that you could kind of
take what's a private sector tool of
micro under entrepreneurship and
starting your own business um and that
could actually be a replacement for
traditional forms of welfare and
particularly forms of um of of kind of
cash assistance so
that's what bill clinton touts and the
idea is that i mean it removes the kind
of social safety net and leaves leaves
poor people up to the kind of whims of
the market so the way it was sold is
kind of like turn your hobby into a
business so you can instead of needing
sort of the the um support of government
you can kind of be your own entrepreneur
and that's one kind of program that was
adopted um i can give a couple other
examples too but this idea of another
one would be kind of turning to um
there's um in terms of housing the the
program which comes known as hope 6
which is
which is a public private um mixed
income program so taking away like the
kind of big public housing prog big hub
public housing developments um in
chicago the the most iconic ones are
cabrini green um or the robert taylor
homes an intense ins instead turning to
these more kind of um
kind of townhouse style developments um
that can kind of earn a profit um and
will um at the same time that will help
people and so that's another kind of
approach that com that comes in that is
addressing this kind of critical problem
of housing um but in a way that's kind
of using the private sector um the book
also looks at things like charter
schools as a key example of this too
which is a kind of mechanism using the
mechanisms of the market um so charter
schools at least how the democratic
party in the 90s promoted it was not
about making a profit but was about
using the techniques of the private
sector
to make um make public schools more
efficient and accountable and so all of
those are kind of efforts to kind of
address these what what traditionally
all of those um welfare housing schools
um the idea is that those are kind of
critical components of of what the
public sector should be doing and um
what we rely on government to do and
instead you're kind of taking mechanisms
of the private sector to do that and it
seems at least in some cases when these
mechanisms or initiatives are created
it's also used as a justification
to cut
other programs and and it seems that it
ends up being sort of zero sum in a
sense
yeah that's i think that's absolutely
right so one of the things i look at the
book is there's a lot of this language
that these are win-wins um because in a
lot of the a lot of the ideas is that
it's um and another kind of critical
program that i look at is like efforts
to kind of um
turn treat um poor communities like
their parts of the global south and kind
of bring corporate investment to them so
like the same way that globalization was
working internationally they used to
bring private sector investment and
that's like helps the community brings
jobs brings walgreens um but at the same
and also helps companies like walgreens
gain a profit and so it's a win-win but
it's actually in many ways a
zero sum
in the fact that like who benefits and
that
in that mechanism is like companies more
than the kind of places or people who
live there
when i recently interviewed um gary
stevenson who's an inequality economist
he said that of everything he's looked
at and studied extensively that at the
end of the day the most effective way to
reduce inequality is through government
taxation basically a government deciding
here's how we're going to use taxation
we're going to and you know the specific
policies are of course to be discussed
but that that's really the way to do it
is your experience that that is the most
effective
yeah i think it's taxation coupled with
intense government spending and just
spending by the by the federal
government and by state governments um
into providing for people so the comedy
and that is that's often achieved
through taxation um of um
largely of the wealthy and that's really
important i mean i think because one of
the ways that this this kind of approach
and so it really kind of um comes into
fruition in the 90s under on during the
clinton administration is this idea of
um and the clinton administration did
enact some some modest um
taxes on the wealthy but not i mean not
to the kind of full extent but the i
their idea was really that you
um give corporations and wealthy people
the sort of opportunities to help rather
than actually making them make any kind
of real sacrifice and that's kind of
what taxi like a taxation approach would
do that it would reduce inequality and
in those terms and make more funding of
it money available to help people um in
need and sort of rebuild um rebuild or
should have a vibrant social safety net
so i mean i think the this next question
it's sort of like an economics question
but i think it's also a history question
and of course you can answer it in
whichever way you think is appropriate
um
when when when i hear sometimes some on
the left who they're not taken super
seriously in most cases but they talk
about a 73 percent marginal tax rate or
a 78 on really really high incomes i
understand the math of it and i
understand the studies about government
revenue is maximized when you have yet
that top tax rate at about 73 percent
and i get it
but it also seems completely politically
uh infeasible right now
and also there's this major issue of no
matter what the rates are there's lots
of ways to get around paying anything at
all in deductions and loopholes and the
way businesses and other things are used
so from uh from a historical perspective
in terms of what's viable and what's
acceptable to populations where do you
think the democratic party should be on
tax policy
well i think there is i mean i think
what has been um
largely popular has been this idea of
and i and so and i don't know the exact
i can't do the exact numbers i was
i'm terrible at math so i don't want to
give you or anyone else the wrong
impression but i think that um one of
the things that comes up with that is
that actually i do think that that
message of that um that corporations and
wealthy people should be held
responsible and should not be kind of um
and that goes with both sort of what
they're paying but also that those
loopholes need to be closed and i think
that actually has been a really popular
message um both um and you saw it in
bernie sanders and elizabeth warren's
campaigns and i think that that actually
that has bipartisan appeal to some to
some degree too so that is a popular
message i think when it's when you get
into the numbers probably that it's more
it's more complicated i think one of the
issues that goes to this too is that
you'd actually need with that closing
things like the corporate um corporate
loopholes and various different other
things is that actually goes to
regulation um and that's another kind of
critical piece and so i think one of the
things i looked at in the book is the
ways in which so much of um and this
goes to kind of thinking about what
republicans and democrats have done that
um especially during the clinton era
there was so much deregulation
of the financial of the financial and
tech sectors um and that's really
contributed to some of these kinds of
inequalities too so it's both in terms
of
regulation in various different
capacities that actually do force
corporations to pay more of their share
um that is a way of kind of addressing
some of these kind of major structural
inequities that exist it also seems that
sometimes it's not i don't want to say
it's difficult like people don't have
the cognitive capacity but it's just
people are busy and they have lives and
so
the idea of well let's raise taxes on
the rich okay right but usually that
means income taxes and the very rich
often don't pay income tax because
they're earning money through other
means okay well then let's raise capital
gains rates like okay well you can do
that but then instead of selling stock
you can pledge the stock as collateral
for a loan which is is another mechanism
that's used and it's not that people
can't understand these things but it's
most people aren't you know buried in
these things day to day because they're
working and so on and so forth it seems
that that also is sort of a difficulty
even when a solution is proposed that
isn't really a solution like just
raising income tax rates so there's a
communication aspect to this
yeah absolutely and i think that there's
a that's a really important point this
is these are really complicated
things and the kind of mechanisms that
are used are hard to
understand to a sound bite and so you
can lose i mean you can um your eyes can
glaze over it just doesn't make any
sense and it doesn't seem like it's
affecting day-to-day life in various
different ways i think for the average
kind of
the average person um and i think the
other kind of piece of that too um is
the ways in which so i think this goes
to the way we think about inequality and
this also goes back to like sort of in
um my book i looked primarily at the
kind of this period of the 90s when
there is kind of large economic growth
if you look back in the 90s with some
nostalgia of this period of like and and
so that's um that's
one of the things that happened i mean
is that you have overall economic growth
but inequality um increasing and i think
the other kind of key piece of that is
taking away these components of the
social safety net and sort of turning to
the private sector and the market to
solve those problems created a creates a
system of profound kind of vulnerability
and um and
predation by corporations so that's sort
of some of the kind of the products of
some of these these issues too
coupled with
huge amounts of um private
personal private wealth being amassed
over the 90s but in these with other
kinds of mechanisms such to use them and
i will go back to saying i don't think
this was just this is just that all of
this falls
you know solely on the democratic party
um i think the republican party and the
and particularly the georgia bush
administration played a really important
role in kind of widening a lot of these
kinds of policies but i do think it's
really important to understand where the
democrats have been
complicit in many ways and and pushed
them
in um in
different avenues yeah bill clinton
you've mentioned bill clinton a a couple
of times and bill clinton will often get
arguably deserved amount of blame for
this but also i mean 1994 and newt
gingrich coming into the house of
representatives and that huge push for
deregulation and and so on and so forth
and then george w bush as well
precipitating um the 2008 recession
there seems to be a lot of blame to go
around here
i think totally and so that's one of the
things is that sort of um in trying to
kind of parse some of that out and to
sort of understand and the other thing
that i really tried to do in my book
which i think is also really important
um are
twofold one um isn't is understanding
what the democrats
and particularly people like bill
clinton and the other kind of new
democrats of the democratic leadership
council
what they um
believed and what they did um and that
and also that those are not sort of
indistinguishable from the republican
party that there are actually
distinctions in in the kinds of policies
and the reasons for why democrats versus
republicans pursue particular ideas and
that there was a genuine belief that
stimulating the private sector and
stimulating certain forms of new
economic growth and tech finance and
trade would be a mec a way to address
great forms of social equality um and
but that's not what played what ended up
happening and so that's really what i've
like tried to understand through my um
through my work last thing i want to ask
about often when i ask folks what is the
model of a country that has sort of done
this correctly
uh usually you hear countries in
northern europe or denmark sweden norway
etcetera and everybody just kind of
shrugs their shoulders and and you know
stops talking about it are are those
actually the models are there models are
there successful uh examples to look at
of course
i've been watching so much morgan and i
feel like that's a great show yeah i'm
watching this new season it's great it's
great um i strongly recommended it but i
imagine it's like this is incredible
yeah um no i think i mean i think that
those are always the places but i think
the really important thing about that i
mean when i look at those places is
they're really homogenous um and
traditionally and so where social we
sort of look to
these um these european countries as
kind of the um as the kind of mecca but
they've had huge issues and tensions um
over immigration and sort of who is part
of their social of their social welfare
and i think that's actually a really
another sort of critical piece in the
united states um is the ways in which
inequality sort of
becomes kind of immersed with questions
of of um
of race and how that operates and sort
of who is worthy of certain kinds of
assistance and so i do think that many
um many western european countries are
also experiencing the same kinds of
questions um today but i do think the
ways in which they've the commitments to
social spending and to having a kind of
robust social safety net um and social
well um is is critical i know and
because i know you've mentioned the the
viewers but you are to your um that you
just had a baby and when you look at the
kind of differences of what um
what parental and child child care are
in many um in many
um western european countries it's like
it's astounding to the difference in the
united states so on those levels i do
think there's and that does that does
contribute to forms of inequity of sort
of fundamental inequity in the united
states so i do think that there is a
place and um i mean denmark is a country
of six million people so we shouldn't
all move there but right i do have it's
like a state in the us basically yeah
yeah yeah
the book is left behind the democrats
failed attempt to solve inequality we've
been speaking with the books author
professor of history at claremont
mckenna college lily geismer really
appreciate your time today
oh thank you so much for having me on
us on social media interact with the
david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
so there's been some super interesting
testimony this week about reproductive
rights and abortion and uh
care for pregnant women in the aftermath
of roe v wade being overturned by the
supreme court and the republicans on
this this congressional panel have been
just embarrassing themselves day after
day after day and today i want to look
specifically at a series of questions
from republican congressman ralph norman
who represents south carolina's fifth
district he
completely humiliated himself with these
questions about
post-birth abortion abortion after birth
which quite literally just doesn't exist
it's not a thing
when when a baby dies after birth when
it's not an abortion we're talking about
something completely different and rene
shannon who's a democratic state rep
from georgia and others did the best
they could to keep up with these absurd
questions and see if you can
find the full list like some of them
will be obvious but see if you can
really find the full list of fallacious
claims by this guy you agree with
infanticide well i think okay so first
of all do you agree with infanticide
already we're talk what what are you
talking about infanticide are we talking
about abortion here or are we talking
about murder when kids are out in the
world using um inflammatory language to
basically describe a situation that does
not happen we don't have infanticide
happening doctors would not do that and
neither would folks who have carried
okay would a healthy child do you agree
if a healthy child is born
that is that woman's right to decide if
it lives or dies what i think is based
on your question you have a very low
opinion of pregnant people because if
you think about anybody answer the
question excuse me answer the question
i'm answering it do you no you're not
you want to answer
witnesses what i'm telling you is nobody
would carry a pregnancy and then decide
on a monday because they are bored that
they want to have an abortion that's
ridiculous and it's inflammatory what
you're saying you're talking about
families who are in tough situations
where folks have been excited about
carrying a pregnancy most of the
abortions that happen later in pregnancy
are really tragedies where it's really a
disappointment for everyone involved but
you agree with i take it with all those
words uh you do agree with basically
murdering a child and
after they're born miss uh miss grave
now this is supposed to be about
abortion this isn't about murdering
children after they're born it's it's
quite literally
a completely different question could
you answer that would you just yes or no
i have to say
congressman
how you just characterize the
representative statement is is extremely
inflammatory in the type of thing that
it's dangerous and what you guys have
been talking today about the threats
against crisis pregnancy centers which i
assume are are serious and yeah by the
way crisis pregnancy centers are places
that convince women not to get abortions
they're terrible
the threats aren't eliminated
i'm not letting you reclaiming my time
i'm assuming that you're in fantasy
i would also say
language
madam chairman okay
this is generally absurd now this guy is
an embarrassment to himself and to his
state and to his constituents there's no
doubt about it
nobody supports abortion after birth
because there is no such thing now
all of the questions this guy's asking
are obviously bad faith questions the
questions are being asked in order not
to be answered
and i do think that the witnesses could
have been better prepared for how to
answer them like i get that they're bad
faith questions
they want you not to answer by making it
a bad faith question
so that then you look bad i believe the
best approach is answer it and then
explain that the question's absurd and
it's a frustrating thing all around to
watch because this guy
is such an embarrassment i mean it's so
it's hard to imagine a worst faith
line of questioning on what is a very
serious issue but he should have been
dunked on for equating abortion with
murder nobody's really even
they're talking past each other in a
certain sense it's not an abortion
because birth happened it's a
mind-numbingly stupid question but they
should be able to say
no we're not for that and that has
nothing to do with decisions
very difficult decisions that relatively
few families have to make in the third
trimester they they are two completely
different things they continue to
stretch this cartoonification of
abortion into well
is it okay to kill a child one month
after they're born what about six months
well what about just deciding at two
years old you're not liking this
parenthood thing so
it they the question can be answered
congressman of course i'm not for
infanticide and what we're talking about
here
are um
there's it's not there's not a
pediatrician involved there's an ob gyn
because what we're talking about here
is a pregnancy it's still a pregnancy at
seven months eight months etc and it's
exceedingly rare nobody goes in
a week before their due date and says
you know what
i want to get an abortion every ob gyn
who has testified over the last two
weeks on that says it never happens and
we wouldn't do it now could you find
someone that would say sure i'll do it
probably you could find someone doesn't
mean it's even something that's
happening uh but the the the questions
are designed for you to feel like you
can't answer them so that you don't
so that norman can go and say since
you're not answering i must assume
you're okay with infanticide the entire
thing is mind-numbingly stupid they
could have been better prepared he's
still embarrassing he still should be
embarrassed uh but they could have been
better prepared
okay
dozens of you have asked me to address
this issue and i'm ready to address it
today i've been waiting
for the story to develop a little bit
some of you might remember
this guy named jessie lee peterson
jesse lee peterson is sort of a
prominent
uh black conservative he's a christian
pastor he has a men's counseling center
in los angeles which i've been to when i
was on jesse's program a couple of years
ago his studio and his radio show all go
out of the same building i believe it's
called the bond
in los angeles and um it turns out it
appears that the very openly homophobic
anti-gay christian pastor jesse lee
peterson is gay
and i'm going to talk about my
experience with him which included him
being pretty handsy with me to be
perfectly honest i wasn't sexually
harassed i didn't feel intimidated or
anything but at the time i just wrote it
off to this this guy's just a character
that does you know he's just pansy but
i'm gonna get back to that okay so
here's the story
um
the daily beast now reporting
allegations of manosphere pastors gay
past royal macho men
jesse lee peterson has emerged as one of
the wright's most vocal anti-gay figures
but his one-time friends now allege that
the pastor has had many same-sex
relationships there are so i'm not going
to give you every claim
but there are so many stories now of
people saying
i i was involved in uh in sexual like
men saying i was involved in sexual
activity with jesse lee peterson he um
comes on to people aggressively in many
cases etc two of uh
two of peter's oh hold on let me go back
two of peterson's former male associates
came out in june with on the record
interviews saying they engaged in sexual
activities with them other men say he
propositioned them these allegations
about the pastor who is publicly
staunchly heterosexual have ripped like
an earthquake through the manosphere
prompting some peterson allies to
abandon him and prompting one manosphere
conference to ban him altogether
the daily beast was not able to
substantiate the allegations peterson's
ministry
a brotherhood organization known as bond
did not respond to multiple requests for
comment okay so what's my view on this
i don't care about his uh sexuality per
se i i really could not care less at
this point i i just don't care about
people's sexual orientation it's boring
to me it i just don't care now jessie
lee peterson is definitely an odd guy
he
is um seemingly obsessed with talking
despite being a black man talking about
how great white people are and how
terrible black people are and he's also
obsessed with talking about how terrible
and sinful and horrible it is to be gay
and he supposedly counsels young men out
of being gay or at least that's what he
claims to do
and it seems as though he is also gay
himself okay
um
what i can tell you is that
the vibe at his counseling office was
really really weird so let me tell you
what i personally observed
was he handsy at his office he was
um he kept you know when we took
pictures
he was sort of like weirdly hugging me
arm around me in a way that's like it's
not
it doesn't raise any red flag
i didn't think he was coming on to me i
didn't feel intimidated or whatever
there were people around but it was just
like it was the first time i was meeting
him and he was a little bit handsy and i
didn't really think anything of it now
in this context
maybe that was something sort of
different he was kind of like whispering
into my ear like not sweet nothings it
was actually about trump he was like and
i've said this before like you're going
to vote for trump aren't you david
you're going to vote for trump and i
quite literally thought absolutely
nothing of it like nothing at all like
what people are describing
the atmosphere
at his office with young men kind of
hanging around
the fact that he counsels young men with
christian counseling i did find it all
weird but not because i thought it was a
way for him to proposition dudes because
it just seemed like this is the last guy
who should be counseling young men and
of course he takes advantage of this
entire thing where as many of you know
to say one is a therapist you actually
need a license you either need to be a
psychologist or
a licensed social worker licensed
independent social worker psychiatrist
licensed mental health counselor he was
none of these things the term counselor
or coach can be used by anybody and he
claimed to be a counselor and of course
he's just a pastor he doesn't actually
have any therapy credentials and that
was the biggest red flag and there were
all these young young men hanging around
and it was odd so is it a shock i mean
not really in the sense that we've seen
now dozens of the most openly
and notably homophobic
christian figures actually be gay
themselves in that sense it's not really
a shock it's only sort of surprising
because this is the only one that i
personally know and who's you know i
went i was with him at his office and
all of these different things so that
that's really all i have to say about it
it's not
i mean you know it's it's not
when people started emailing me saying
david it turns out jesse lee peterson is
gay okay i mean that's my concern is
more about
what are the the the lives that he has
potentially ruined now one other thing
there was this interesting moment
jesse lee peters is all about alpha the
alpha male and he says if you're on the
left you're beta he's called me a beta
male and we had an interview
where i asked him are you like are you
in a relationship are you
um are you sexually active or whatever
and he said that he's off sex
and he's off sex because
out of wedlock i think was the term he
used you know it's inappropriate or
whatever but he seemed visibly
uncomfortable with the line of
questioning and again is it all related
to this entire
hidden homosexuality thing that's going
on maybe i don't know you know in
retrospect hindsight starts to become
clearer and clearer but i don't really
know that any one of these things is
sort of like a big oh it should have
been obvious that he was one of these
homophobic gay guys i i can't i really
can't say that i can only speak to my
personal experience and that's what it
is very um i mean it's a sad story it's
not sad that he's gay it's sad that he's
gay and homophobic that's always sad
when people can't just be who they are
and also
that i have a very strange feeling about
the entire counseling of young men
quite frankly we're talking about boys
in many cases
uh that he was doing and who knows what
else we may learn about this in the
future that's about it we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p
here's a very disturbing disturbing
coveted conspiracy theorist who called
in listen to this
yo pax what up man total control 871 yo
what's up with the surge from what i
understand the covet is surging again
but why does it always surge in the
communist controlled states the deep
blue states where it's surge surging oh
my god it surges what can i say i'm
sorry sorry about that you know the the
surge it catches one unawares and what
can i say you know guys like me over 50
shot free and coveted free for some
strange reason i never get sick
so this is what we call
extrapolating inaccurately from an
anecdote
there are tens of millions of people
who have not had covet and some of them
are unvaccinated and the fact that this
caller
didn't get covered and isn't vaccinated
tells us actually nothing about the
pandemic that's so weird it's almost
like the pandemic doesn't exist right
and and so that's what we call
extrapolating too far
he didn't get sick
so it must all be imaginary hey we know
that's crazy talk you know that's a
conspiracy thing surge surge
sorry sorry dave
that was a real surge that was a real
strong surge oh my god that was
i think i almost went blind with that
one
oh my god i just searched all over
myself all right so as you can see
these are not exactly the types of folks
that you can really speak rationally
with that guy actually called into the
show once about a year and a half ago
and his talking points were pretty
similar it's tough to get everybody on
the same page about basic facts when
you've got people who believe stuff like
that that that's where we can leave it
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today won't even tell you what's on it
you'll just have to tune in to see
get instant access to the bonus show by
signing up at
joinpackman.com and you can use the
coupon code big voting22 to get a
discount if you so choose
you